ciudad de méxico- y el colindante estado
de méxico unas regiones que son el hogar
de más de 20 millones de personas
reciben las fiestas navideñas bajo
aislamiento entre los motivos una
ocupación hospitalaria que supera el 75%
desde este sábado y hasta el 10 de enero
en estas zonas se cierran las
actividades no esenciales tales como los
gimnasios y los restaurantes con
atención en el local la capital mexicana
entró en el denominado semáforo rojo y
aunque desde el gremio de los
comerciantes lamentan esta decisión las
autoridades lo consideran como necesario
es han seguido aumentando los contagios
y han seguido aumentando las
hospitalizaciones que es pues en
realidad lo que más nos preocupa y
también el incremento de lamentables de
función y el ritmo al que siguen los
contagios es un ritmo preocupante
y esto nos lleva a que tomemos medidas
drásticas para frenar el ritmo de
contagio ningún estado del país supera
la tasa de incidencia de kobe 19 por
cada 100.000 habitantes que tiene la
capital la cifra es de tres mil setenta
y nueve personas por encima de la media
nacional fijada en poco más de 1000
personas a nivel nacional el panorama no
es el mejor si hablamos de los muertos
por cada 100 contagios una tasa del 9%
ningún otro país del mundo vive una
situación similar según la universidad
johns hopkins la esperanza está puesta
en la vacuna y con miras a comenzar este
plan a finales de diciembre el viernes
se desarrolló un simulacro utilizando la
vacuna contra la influenza el objetivo
medir la logística y los tiempos para
cuando llegue la hora de aplicar las
inyecciones de manera masiva